Speaker 1: Whenever there is a major scandal that
rocks the political world, it sometimes takes a
little while to figure out which talking points
politicians are going to attach themselves to.
In the immediate aftermath of the FBI serving
the search warrant on Donald Trump's Mar a Lago
earlier this week, we heard a bunch of different
things floated from Republicans we heard about.
This could be the start of an assassination
attempt that made no sense. There's no evidence
of that we heard about. This is an abuse of power.
We heard all sorts of different things. But the
one that they seem to be sticking with is the FBI
planted evidence. Now, the Trump people have not
even released the search warrant and it seems as
though they're not going to. The latest reports I
saw this morning are that they are not releasing
the search warrant. There is absolutely no
evidence whatsoever that the FBI planted anything.
There is also it's sort of hard to believe that in
a in a case of this high profile, that that is
the approach that the FBI would take. If anything,
my instinct is that the FBI would rather not
have done this at all, because all of a sudden
now Merrick Garland is getting death threats.
Christopher Wray is getting death threats. It's
crazy what is going on. I don't think that this is
something they would do just for fun. But put that
aside for a second. They are sticking with the FBI
planted evidence. I had half a dozen examples for
you of this over the last couple of days. And now
people in greater and greater positions of power
are starting to repeat this one. Here is
Republican Senator Rand Paul, who is also floating
without any evidence whatsoever that the FBI may
be planting evidence. Take a listen to this. And
it's a it's seen as acceptable by many on
the right for Rand Paul to make this claim,
absent any reason to believe it's true.
Speaker 2: You know, people distrust
so much the government that we've gotten to the
point where, for example, do I know that the boxes
of material they took from Mar a Lago that they
won't put things in those boxes to entrap him?
How do we know their lawyers weren't allowed
to see the boxes go? They weren't categorized.
Going to be a pile of documents were taken.
Speaker 1: Well, Rand, is there any reason to
believe that such a thing was done? Because for
everybody mentioning the planting of evidence,
no one has been able to present any actual
reason to believe that that happened.
Speaker 2: How do we know that? They're
going to be honest with us about what's actually
in the boxes? How do we know that was in the box
before it left? The residence of the lawyers
weren't allowed to see everything. So, you know,
they've lost a great deal of trust in it.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So there's Rand Paul
asserting it. And this is sort of the anatomy of
a conspiracy theory. It will often start sort of
quietly as an aside with the most partizan
people. Trump's lawyers, for example, going,
Listen, it wouldn't shock me if they
even planted evidence. Oh, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah. And then people like Fox News hosts
start latching on to it. And we played a number
of examples of that from yesterday. And next
thing you know, sitting senators and sitting
members of Congress are doing the same thing. It
almost seemed like Marjorie Taylor GREENE got it
from an oann host. Here is Marjorie Taylor GREENE
yesterday nodding along as an oann host says
maybe evidence was planted and then I'll show
you how later in the day she makes it her own.
Speaker 3: In all of that, all of the documents
and everything President Trump had at Mar a Lago,
that isn't anything that the FBI
needed to raid his home for that.
Speaker 2: No, we were to talk about her. The
GSA approved it. The GSA approved the documents,
mailed them, sealed them and sent them to him.
So why would the government give them to him for
another government to come take them back?
Speaker 1: That's completely untrue,
by the way, but that's not the focus today.
Speaker 2: Unless they're planting something.
Anyway, I got to switch back because
we're really almost out of time. George,
I knew this would happen because you and I are.
Speaker 1: So Marjorie Taylor GREENE saying about
they unless they plan to plant evidence. Yeah and
right. And then later in the day Marjorie Taylor
GREENE going full fledged in on this tweeting
quote, I think now look at the language, right? I
think so. It's that that's your thinking. You
don't have evidence. I think that there is an
extremely high probability that the FBI planted
evidence against President Trump. Otherwise,
why would they not allow his attorneys
or anyone watch them while they conducted
their unprecedented raid? They know the
consequences of an empty handed power move. This
rings completely and totally hollow. It just
doesn't pass the sniff test. And let me also
talk a little bit about Marjorie Taylor Greene's
use of the word unprecedented. Yesterday,
we talked about Marsha Blackburn's comment. If
they can do this to Trump, they can do this to
anyone, to which we said they already do it to
anyone. The question is, will they ever do it
to people in positions of power? The other one
that Trump and others have been talking about is
that this was an unprecedented. Raed. First of
all, you know, I've been guilty of this as well.
The FBI doesn't really do raids.
I mean, this wasn't really a raid.
They had a search warrant and they served it.
That that's what that's what it was. It was a
search warrant. They executed a search warrant.
So the use of raid, it's colloquially used. And
I do it as well. But understand that this this
was they served a search warrant. Unprecedented
is a big focus for them. Trump said. No, this
has never happened to any president before.
And now a lot of these right wingers have latched
on to the idea of unprecedented. Well, if it's
never been done before, then it must be wrong.
We've never had a president who did the things
that Donald Trump did. So it's logical that, I
mean, sort of like a mathematical equation. When
you have unique inputs, you will have a unique
output. And we're starting with a president who
did things no other president has done. It's
logical. It would be to be expected that the
outcomes also are unlike those that we have
seen before. And one such outcome is indeed
a search warrant being served by the FBI on
Donald Trump's home. There is no evidence that
they planted evidence. If we ever learn that
the FBI planted evidence, I will tell you that
and I will absolutely condemn it for now.
There's no reason to think that that took place